ci vogliono fare a fettine non sono
stato io
benvenuti sola parte oggi il nuovissimo
episodio è che i forum des maitres che i
forum lasciate un bel mi piace qui sotto
mettetevi comodi prima però mi seguite
anche la suite tramandati a voce
skiforum stiamo in ospedale dobbiamo
scappare dal medico basso guardate qui
lui riuscirà a evitare questa volta
[Musica]
sparare è una schiappa
e allora opportuno che tutto ok
attenzione attenzione inizia male questo
escape room perché ok prova a saltare la
qua ce l'ha fatta la grazia che anzi
sono super difficili questi qua dove si
deve saltare secondo soprattutto perché
io paura delle altezze non lo so mi fa
un po di impressione che secondo me del
gioco ovviamente continuate a
consigliarci le ski promo le mappe da
provare su robles grazie mille perché
negli sforzi video se non li avete visti
andate a vederli abbiamo fatto le skifo
room nella prigione però il parco di
divertimenti pauroso e ci avete
consigliato un sacco di mahler box
continuate a consigliarci né qua sotto
finora questa è molto divertente italy
dove finisca prezzo di last stand di
quadratini roy siamo ecco vitale
prendiamo come amore ciao raga io sono
qui alla fine
se ha fatto credo arrivato qua allora
adesso guarda c'è uno scheletro giganti
che parte dobbiamo andare di qua
dobbiamo saltare su queste queste luci
attenta risultare furioso 9 delitto
vital kamerhe troppo difficile queste
schede prum molto più difficile della
prigione pochettino si è che ansia o dai
io sono arrivato è che ce la puoi fare
perché ce la posso fare ancora un paio
ce la posso fare
dai me ne manca solo dai solo un paio
aiuto infinito brava l'ultima si sbaglia
sempre loro i pulsanti viene capita di
andare piano piano non guardare giù non
pervenuto no io lo guardo il piano piano
cave
non passarmi davanti mi fai cadere o
avete lasciato mi piace ribelle che
avete lasciato lascia se vi piace così
ci portate fortuna ha cliccato mi piace
qui ci avete portato davvero fortuna non
ho altri salti adoro queste questi sono
facili dai basta prendere un po di
ricordati è vero per poi esistono facili
ok adesso dove dobbiamo andare qui in
questa porta speriamo che dobbiamo più
saltare è il nome non detto e difficile
dovete far saltare ok attenzione perché
da qualche parte potrebbe anche
nascondersi il medico pazzo gli daremo
anche lo pochissimi non possa accadere
adesso ma dovetti tanto sono qui dentro
di te casa superato questo infermiere ha
detto che posso solo andare giù quindi
devo buttarmi ok
perché siamo tornati salviamo
no so già che qua morirò un sacco di
voci poté floris lava ok
finora tutto bene tutto liscio io cado
solo se siamo tanto in alto mi viene
l'ansia assistiamo quasi un fatto ma
disse che questo pezzo giallo mi farà
correre più veloce mi devo fidare
secondo te
vediamo che allora bisogna correre qua
wow oh wow voglio sempre correre così
veloce rigoletto non si poteva che
ancora non sono morta wow non è stato
troppo divertente giornata
e questo uno sembrano un ascensore si
porta a soli di wow è troppo divertente
e fammi salvare la vita fosse una porta
e tali da dove
ci vogliono fare a fettine in sé di
nascondersi prima che arrivi il dottore
cattivo io non porto non ci possiamo
nascondere qui dove trovare un altro
tifoso attenta non accampo più grande
che ami posso nascondere dentro la base
alle 6 nella bocca del paziente ma
seriamente come sono niente tutti
affettata entrato dentro la bocca si ok
prova raggiungerti primo che non arrivi
subito al dottore ok ha abbassato il
braccio il bravo dice l'ugola ora
sappiamo se questo che cos'è allora i
suoi denti big ci dobbiamo nascondere
qui ho detto aiuto devo capirlo perché
non nascondiamoci nel gigante per un po
penso che sta arrivando storia bertone
ha tuttavia quando andare lì benissimo
la regione la bocca scivoliamo il labor
day
bisogna salire qui si sa dove stiamo
andando
che cosa quando il cuore attento evita
syracuse viola e così virano che the ok
via so dove può saltare di là appena
talento ad ottenere qua sotto forti
ficile anche questo comunque finora è
bellissimo che si sa bene come perché
ora iniziato da qua sotto
quando finiamo l'escape room dategli un
voto da 1 a 10 perché noi gli daremo un
voto da 1 a 10 anti scriveteci poi qual
è stata la vostra parte preferita come
vi diremo la nostra parte preferita
io sto sempre chedendo sfracellato quasi
fatecelo quasi fatto noto dai tuffi
sbrigati anzi io vado a salvare ciò che
inizia andare su
ecco perché sei pronto a cadere dieci
volte ecco bisogna andare nella parte
più larga della forza è che parte del
corpo è questa dovete possa dire no a
dice di scegliere una di queste strade
sono in uno si può camminare un
misterioso scegliere quello giusto o no
ma come faccio a indovinarlo book è
riuscito ti dico io quale prendere ok
sembrare kanemoto e poi qua devo
indovinare quale potrebbe che ti seguo
allora bravo bravo ora vai tutta
criticati tu allora secondo me è quello
centrale
vediamo allora parliamo poi quello che
cos'è questa la spina dorsale
wow quindi era l'ultimo qui invece
giusta grande grazie ma cosa cerchi sono
caduta forse bisogna saltare ce la posso
fare ce la posso fare è difficile o capo
i prati aspetto che fa troppo ridere
nessuno che fa capo a bisogna che questo
la spina dorsale con il cuore
saliamo dove arriveremo alla testa forse
riusciamo a scappare adesso che cosa
questo attento non portiamo prende piano
piano e vitale
ecco non ho capito conosciuti a spezzano
si no
attenzione perché qua ti fa correre
velocissime devi saltare ok ok ho
salvato aiuto
[Musica]
[Risate]
espulso forse dobbiamo scappare dal
gabinetto adesso perché sembrano delle
tubature queste che i ragazzi ecco qua
sono nel gabinetto sospettato che
essendo a vitale bene ora siamo delle
foglie dei contento quanto tantissimo si
possa lavorare
forse stiamo per uscire dall escape from
fa non si è fatta qui dietro di
trattenute su dal vino rosso lobby di un
cortile cosa fare adesso forse lo
abbiamo fatto i diavoli abbiamo salvato
che cosa sta succedendo ad c'è scritto
che abbiamo vinto ma l'ultima sfida è
trovare la medaglia segreta forse questa
oppure qui già fatto
ho visto una specie di medaglia forze
sulla sua in alto sul jan fabre
qui vediamo prova a saltare anch'io vedi
c'è qualcosa di giallo lo so vediamo se
ci riesco
soltanto eccomi io non lo trovo questo
medaglione aspetto perché succede forse
sono morta forse quello con il giallo
no io ci sono andato prima non sono
riuscito a prenderla vediamo del rischio
di andarci un po a no non era questo non
è un medaglione però devo dire che super
divertente sembra di poter volare
guardate c'è qualcosa laggiù si potrà
andare così mentre non avete moriamo
proviamo ad andare a guasto volando io
ci prova di vino prodotto
così blocca tipo ti fa cadere a pezzi e
personali quello che succede forse
bisogna entrare qua dentro
so provato prima però non so non mi fa
scendere
no non è come supermario non abbiamo
trovato il medaglione ma abbiamo vinta
separate l'escape roma dove è stato
super divertente io da un bell 8 e mezzo
di ieri don 9 perché mi ha fatto un
sacco ridere che possa vi dentro è stata
la nella partita soprattutto il
gabinetto web
abbiamo tutti i dati con è stato il
vostro momento preferito per me quello
del gabinetto che si è anche sempre più
bello basta non mi piace se volete
vedere altri giochi dirò basta trek che
pur un'estate mi piace alla fine avremo
quattro cose lì che ci azzecca cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri vigili cade su
quella che preferite una visione